so there are certain systems that are in
the United States right now that seem to
be able to provide better value based
care these systems that are commonly
mentioned or Keizer or mayo clinic or
geisinger and what they do is that they
have the ability to provide care across
the continuum so if you see someone
within the system you're likely to be
referred to somebody else within the
system and that information that you
that you is obtained from the first
person you saw is seen by that second
person so you reduce the costs of
repetition additionally those systems
tend to control their administrative
costs a lot tighter and they also tend
to follow certain things like formulary
restrictions and they have decision
support for their physicians in the
electronic medical records that they use
and they all have basically a hundred
percent electronic medical record
utilization
electronic medical records are important
because they allow for information
sharing the problem with electronic
medical records is that if there are a
hundred different vendors and therefore
a hundred different records that
information cannot be shared across
so-called systems so if you as provider
ex has a certain system in me as
provider why has a different system
those in for those systems don't share
information in the current state and
Aras as a result the goal of the record
in terms of making information portable
and transferable is lost their very
effective within the system so the tests
aren't repeated you can see tests that
were done previous day or the previous
month they're very good for trending
tests and trending information but the
real promise of the electronic
electronic medical record is not
obtained until you have a way to link
different records with different
information systems so if you would
think of the electronic medical record
as the car so you right now the
administration is buying cars but we
need to build roads so that the cars can
travel and all that information that is
obtained at a practice in Denver can be
seen at a practice in Boston if a
consultation is required in Boston there
the promise of the record starts to come
to fruition additionally the record can
also provide a way for the patient to
have some input of end and access to
information about their care if the
record not only becomes the EMR the
elect the electronic medical record but
becomes a window to the personal health
record I believe that they should be one
in the same that the physician should be
able to see a part of a patient's record
and that the patient should have access
to the same information in a view that
he or she can understand that would
allow the promise of the record to
really be realized because once you
start giving patients
access to their information you start
empowering patients you start empowering
self management and you start really
developing a shared strategy of care
between the patient and the care
provider
I think that the government should also
think about investing in things that
enable patients to take better care of
themselves so again the medical record
is not enough we need something that
patients can see and we need them to
have access to their information whether
it's through readily available
technology like a cell phone or a laptop
or a passkey that they can go to a
public library and get their information
yes there's a question of safety but
that has to be managed appropriately I
think those are the types of things that
that the government should be spending
their money on from a technological
perspective very simple solutions that
people could understand and embrace as
opposed to again whiz-bang things that
that people typically are not going to
use it's not the technology that makes
the difference it's the implementation
scheme and the people behind the
technology that matter